today's video is brought to you by
squarespace the tool to use to make a
website for your brand and grow your
business more about them in a bit
he's america's only double president the
man who took the highest office in the
land lost it after one term and then
came roaring back for a second even if
nothing else grover cleveland's status
as america's only non-consecutive
president would be enough for him to be
remembered it's thanks to him that joe
biden is called the 46th president
despite only 45 people having ever held
the office yet there's more to the
combined 22nd and 24th president than
this piece of trivia cleveland's eight
interrupted years were filled with
striking firsts as the first democrat
elected president between james buchanan
and woodrow wilson cleveland's tenures
form a remarkable interlude in the
post-civil war era two bands of blue on
a chart that is otherwise the deepest of
red in attitude two cleveland was unique
a passionate fiscal conservative he
holds the distinction of being perhaps
the most moderate democrat to ever leave
the party sadly that modernization would
wind up being the very thing that
destroyed his reputation
[Music]
in the grand sweep of presidential
history there are occasional periods of
one-party dominance the democratic
republicans unbeatable winning streak
from 1800 to 1824 say or the new deal
coalition that won fdr and harry truman
combined five elections but perhaps none
of these periods compares to the five
decades after the civil war from
lincoln's election in 1860 right the way
through to the end of taft's one term in
1913
almost no democrats made it to the
highest office of the two that did one
andrew johnson only got there thanks to
lincoln running on a unity ticket and
then getting assassinated had john
wilkes booth's hand trembled slightly it
would have been republicans all the way
with one important exception an
exception who remarkably
never wanted to be president anyway born
stephen grover cleveland on march the
18th 1837 in new jersey the future
democratic president was almost
singularly unambitious a large part of
that was because he couldn't afford to
be as one of nine children grover
cleveland who quickly dropped the
stephen from his name grew up in a
household on the edge of poverty his
father was a presbyterian minister whose
job required them to frequently move
taking them to tiny ass villages in new
york state although cleveland was able
to attend school he didn't do so
regularly by the age of 14 he was
working as a store clerk just to help
support the family despite his lack of
wealth though the future president
didn't lack dreams as a teenager his
main dream was to go to hamilton college
and get a serious education by 1853 it
looked like this dream might come true
the family had saved enough and
cleveland was less than a year away from
turning 17. but then god seems to have
glanced down from heaven and declared
that october cleveland's father died
robbing the family of their main source
of income the old man's passing did to
cleveland's dreams what a sharp pin
cruelly utilized will do to a child's
balloon with college suddenly
unaffordable a young man was forced to
return to work with each dollar he made
going to support his mum and younger
siblings yet this misfortune would soon
turn out to be the making of grover
cleveland after a year spent teaching in
a school for the blind the future
president seems to have hit on a plan
borrowing 25 he traveled to buffalo
where his uncle had promised him a job
clerking at a law firm but this wasn't
just a sideways career move
oh no despite his relative lack of
education cleveland was determined to
become a lawyer that meant four years of
working like mad burning the candle not
just at both ends but in the middle near
the edges and just about every other
conceivable place too all day long
cleveland clerked all through the
evening he studied law cramming like
someone permanently preparing for finals
and it paid off in 1858 this poor boy
from the styx was admitted to the bar
perhaps more importantly though the
experience left cleveland with two
deeply held convictions a certainty in
the value of both hard work and modest
living it would be these convictions
that typified his white house tenure but
first the young lawyer had to get
through the civil war three years after
cleveland passed his exams a south
carolina militia opened fire on fort
sumter kickstarting four long brutal
years but while other future presidents
would answer the call for the union army
cleveland instead paid a polish
immigrant to go fight in his place this
was actually legal at the time still it
wouldn't be a good look for cleveland
being the only president from grant to
mckinley who didn't either fight in the
war or in chester arthur's case had
logistics for the union army regardless
of his level of participation though the
civil war still had one major impact on
cleveland's life as america burned the
young man took the job of assistant
district attorney of erie county
unbeknownst to anyone it would be the
start of cleveland's spectacular journey
into politics
at this stage you're probably expecting
to hear how cleveland's brush with
low-level politics inspired him to climb
the ladder to rise to the top winning
election after election until he finally
won the biggest election of all which
just goes to show how atypical
cleveland's career was we mentioned
before how the future president was
almost singularly unambitious so rather
than finish his tenure as assistant d.a
and then set his sights higher cleveland
instead finished his term then went to
open a law practice with his friend
oscar folsom it wasn't until 1870 that
he drifted back towards politics
becoming sheriff of erie county he held
that position for three years before
once again going back to practicing law
still his short tenure as sheriff
wouldn't be forgotten by cleveland or
his enemies with the county's
executioner often unavailable cleveland
stepped in on multiple occasions as a
substitute it was his hand that pulled
the lever opening the trapdoor and
causing the sickening crack sound as the
condemned neck broke now there's no
suggestion that he enjoyed this task but
it does nicely show the steel that lay a
cleveland's core hidden beneath the
flabby exterior and by this time there
was no doubting that flabby was exactly
what cleveland was becoming always
overweight as a child the future
president entered his fourth decade with
a waistline expanding like the early
universe in part this was due to his
insatiable appetites cleveland drank
like an alcoholic fish he ate like a
gluttonous horse and he hated exercise
once declaring bodily movement alone is
among the dreary and unsatisfying things
of life by 1880 he'd ballooned nearly
280 pounds making him the fattest
president not named william howard taft
not that his weight ever seems to have
bothered the man who was nicknamed uncle
jumbo cleveland was almost perversely
proud of his waistline and diet while
running for sheriff it jokingly promised
to cut down four glasses of beer a day
and then proceeded to take a truly
gigantic glass with him every time he
went out meaning he could drink a gallon
of beer without technically breaking his
word this sense of humor was one of the
reasons everyone in buffalo loved him he
had a common touch the sort of guy who'd
take you fishing beat you at poker and
then buy your drinks all while telling
you some uproarious joke oddly this side
would almost vanish once he got to
washington but it was there at the
beginning and it's one of the reasons
that he went as far as he did in 1881
the democratic party in buffalo began
casting around for a well-liked local to
run as their candidate for mayor with
the jovial overweight cleveland fitting
the bill they asked him if he'd like to
stand caught off guard cleveland agreed
and amazed everyone by winning what was
even more surprising though was that he
even went on to be an excellent mayor
the moment he arrived in city hall the
old core of steel inside cleveland
reawakened instead of simply signing off
on his party's wasteful spending the new
mayor took an axe to buffalo's budget
cutting away the fat leaving behind a
city that was leaner less corrupt and
better run and a secret weapon was the
veto in all of his leadership roles from
buffalo mayor all the way to president
cleveland would become notorious for
vetoing any bill he felt wasted money
remember this was the great era of pork
barrel politics when throwing money at
allies patrons and random passers by was
just how you did things but not grover
cleveland in his single year as
buffalo's mayor cleveland exercised so
much corruption and saved so much money
that he became a public hero not just in
buffalo at state level new york
democrats noticed this rising star and
begged him to run for governor just like
with the buffalo mayoral race cleveland
agreed and just like in buffalo he won
despite having never really sought the
job as 1883 dawned then cleveland was on
a dizzying journey that had taken him to
governor of america's then most popular
state in a mere two years for most
people this would be the pinnacle of
their careers grove cleveland though
was only just getting started
now just before we continue today i do
have to tell you about a surface that
you probably never heard of before never
been mentioned on youtube it's
squarespace and obviously i'm just
kidding everyone knows squarespace
because they are the best place to build
a website in 2022. and look if you need
a website you just shouldn't be
considering anywhere else if it's
entered your thought you know i don't
know what you're making for a business a
blog you're sharing your annoying
political opinions whatever make that
site with squarespace why because
websites are ridiculously easy to make
and feature rich imagine the situation
you know nothing about websites you like
looking at them you know they some of
them look good and you're like i want
that for myself well squarespace you go
in there's a quick quiz and then they
show you recommended templates you look
at those recommended templates you're
like i love that one you click on it you
open it up you swap out some of the text
some of the images and then you are
largely done it's
just ridiculously easy to use plus it's
not just blogs you can sell things
through squarespace which is good if
that's what you want to do plus they've
got email campaigns analytics social
integrations all of that stuff that
you'd expect head to squarespace.com for
a free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com forward
slash biographics to save ten percent of
your first purchase of a website or a
domain and now back to today's video
few politicians have ever had quite as
meteoric arise as grover cleveland just
check out this timeline january 1881
nobody january 1882 mayor of buffalo
january 1883 governor of new york
january of 1885
president that's the sort of leap that
would make stalin's five-year plans look
unambitious
and it was all down to simple
anti-corruption efforts when cleveland
took over new york the state was in the
grip of the democratic machine in
tammany hall the same tammany hall that
helped him get elected but rather than
repaying them cleveland did exactly what
he'd done in buffalo his short tenure
saw him crack down on corruption sweep
away waste and do his level best to
bring tammany hall to heel all of this
made him super popular in new york and
that made democrats super interested in
nominating him for president new york
you see oh was key to the white house in
the previous presidential election 1880
the popular vote had been on a knife
edge with just
1898 votes separating james a garfield
from his democratic pursuer but because
garfield had won new york the electoral
college hadn't even been close ever
since democrats have become convinced
their only path to victory involved
taking new york and who better to
capture the all-important state than its
popular new governor summer 1884 saw
cleveland gain his party's nomination
almost without having to campaign
against him the republicans put up james
g blaine given the gop had won every
election since 1860 they probably felt
they could nominate a pig in a wig and
still somehow win and who knows maybe
miss piggy would have won
but james g blaine didn't he was just
too corrupt too cozy with wall street
even for his party 1884 saw the mugwomb
faction of republicans split off to
support cleveland it was a brutally
damaging moment for blaine one of his
allies tried to deflect by digging up an
old scandal about cleveland fathering a
child out of wedlock but that came back
to bite them when cleveland essentially
put up his hands and said yeah i'd miss
it the kid's probably mine
what do you want to do about it
it was the perfect comeback by telling
the truth cleveland made himself seem
even more honest than ever yet even now
blaine might have still squeaked a win
had it not been for one rather
unfortunate speech at a new york rally
one of blaine's allies told voters
cleveland was the candidate of rum
romanism and rebellion which everyone
took as a swipe at the catholic irish as
a result nyc's thousands of irish
refused to back blame oh when the
results came in the two candidates were
nearly level in the popular vote in new
york though blaine had lost by a mere 1
200 votes with that the state handed
cleveland an electoral college victory
the following march 1885 grover
cleveland became the first democrat
inaugurated president since james
buchanan it was a stunning victory one
made all the more so by being unexpected
for the first time in 30 years a full
generation the democrats had taken the
white house and what would they do now
that they'd finally clawed back that
prize the answer
it soon turned out was
well not a lot as the new york times
stated in cleveland's 1908 obituary the
first term of grover cleveland as
president of the united states was not
made notable by any striking events and
it's here we get to one of the oddest
things about cleveland's tenure despite
being an anti-corruption machine in
buffalo and new york cleveland in
washington was curiously inactive sure
he still went out of his way to protect
public money from wasteful spending even
torpedoing a drought relief bill because
he felt it wasn't the government's job
to bail out farmers sure he still
wielded his veto power it's commonly
accepted that he vetoed more bills than
all previous presidents combined yet he
never tried to use his office to really
change things to push through his vision
of the country because that's not what
he saw the presidency for in cleveland's
mind the president wasn't a leader but a
guardrail against congress a man who
exercised discrete judgment to ensure
the other branches didn't go loopy it
was a self-limiting vision of the
presidency especially compared to what
we expect nowadays but that doesn't mean
there isn't plenty for us to talk about
along with his other attributes grover
cleveland has the distinction of being
one of the only two men to the white
house as a bachelor while others entered
as widows or were widowed while in
office only cleveland and james buchanan
arrived in the oval office having never
been married but while buchanan would
remain a bachelor cleveland would soon
find love in the most unexpected place
francis folsom was cleveland's surprise
choice of bride surprising because she
was both almost 30 years younger than
him and also the daughter of his ex-law
partner in fact cleveland had paid for
her upbringing after her dad died in an
accident yet he wouldn't remain a father
figure for very long in 1885 cleveland
proposed to the girl after she visited
the white house the two were married on
june 2nd 1886 and just like that the 21
year old francis became america's
youngest first lady she took up the role
just as her new husband was really
getting into the swing of his first term
despite not being an activist president
cleveland still had some achievements he
worked to increase the size of the navy
while also establishing the president's
right to appoint his own people in this
case that usually meant promoting people
based on merit cleveland was one of the
first presidents to really pursue a
policy of meritocracy uplifting the
talented at the expense of the
well-connected but while cleveland's
first term had some wins it also had its
controversies the biggest of which
revolved around race as a proud democrat
cleveland represented the party of the
south the party of the lost cause and
jim crow and he took this role seriously
throughout his tenure cleveland made a
point of keeping the white southerners
happy returning confederate flags taken
in battle opposing integrated schools
and treating attempts to restrict black
political participation with a shrug
outside the deep south his record was
more mixed for a while he genuinely
tried to promote the rights of immigrant
chinese workers being exploited in the
west before eventually backtracking and
trying to halt immigration from china
where native americans were concerned
things were even murkier cleveland saw
himself as a friend to america's
indigenous inhabitants and tried to
improve their lives improve in air
quotes here because it basically
involved him going hey why didn't you
guys try uh you know
give it up your culture i'm sure that'll
be totally fine just give it a go come
on overall then cleveland's first term
was a mixed bag quite successful if your
thing is cutting government spending
kind of sucky if your thing is
positive race relations of course no one
at the time knew
this was only his first term especially
after 1888 delivered him a shock defeat
in the run-up to the election cleveland
had started taking aim at tariffs which
he felt forced costs onto customers
cutting them was broadly popular with a
notable exception among industrial
workers whose jobs they protected
industrial workers who just happened to
be a sizeable voting block in key swing
states like new york can't guess what
happened that november when 1888's
results came in it quickly became clear
cleveland had beaten the republican
contender benjamin harrison in the
popular vote unfortunately it
simultaneously lost new york by one
percent in indiana by a razor thin
margin that meant that for only the
third time in history the guy who'd lost
the popular vote would become president
cleveland's term
was over on march the 4th 1889 grover
cleveland left the white house returning
to private life as a lawyer for just
about everyone this must have seemed
like the end of the 22nd president never
before had a one-term wonder staged a
comeback to the highest office in the
land but of course cleveland wouldn't be
just a one-term wonder he may have been
electorally defeated but grover
cleveland wasn't finished he would be
back for one last non-consecutive term
unfortunately it would be the second
term
that destroyed his party
[Music]
despite having just watched a president
torpedo his election chances with tariff
reform it didn't take long for the
republicans to do the exact same thing
in early 1890 rising gop style william
mckinley forced through a new higher a
tariff intended to protect factory jobs
instead it caused a massive spike in
consumer prices just as the u.s stock
market was hit by an equally massive
downturn the result was a republican
shellacking in the midterms the gop shed
93 house seats along with tond national
support suddenly it looked like 1892
might not be an easy second win for
benjamin harrison but whoever the
democrats put up would likely beat the
unpopular president and grover cleveland
wasn't just going to sit back and let
the chance to make history pass him by
november 1892 saw a straight rematch
between cleveland and harrison and while
it was still close the results were far
more decisive than in 1888 as well as
the popular vote cleveland won both new
york and indiana plus a bunch of other
swing states for the first and at least
for now only time in history a president
had been re-elected for a second
non-consecutive term it's hard to
imagine what cleveland must have felt
when he heard the results he was now the
most electorally successful democrat
since andrew jackson the only guy who'd
managed to punch a hole in the gop's
post-civil war dominance well whatever
he was feeling oh we hope he saved it
because it would soon transpire that
cleveland hadn't even won a poisoned
chalice but a chance to be force-fed
manure every single day for four
long years in february 1893 just a month
before cleveland's second inauguration
the economy utterly collapsed like
utterly prior to the great depression
this was by far the greatest depression
on record as banks slammed their doors
the white hot rail industry imploded
that in turn collapsed demand in the
steel industry setting off a chain
reaction of company failures in the
city's unemployment spiked to 25 percent
across the nation as a whole it stood at
nearly a fifth far worse than the great
recession's peak as banks fell people's
savings were wiped out there was so much
demand for aid that charities couldn't
keep up with such a doomsday scenario
it's hard to see how any president could
have emerged with his reputation intact
and while cleveland would really do his
best it would backfire so badly that the
democrats would be wiped out the problem
boiled down to the president's steely
commitment to fiscal conservatism now we
can argue until the cows come home about
whether it's better to splurge like an
incontinent keynesian or lock while it's
tight during a downturn i'm sure plenty
of commenters are already doing so but
the inaugural fact is that if you're
going to tighten the belt you need to be
excellent at communicating it to the
average voter on why he's getting poorer
and it's here that cleveland found
himself out of his depth after a
lifetime of winning plaudits for
cost-saving measures the newly
re-elected president struggled to
articulate why being disciplined was now
more important than ever and that led to
some major pr blunders one came when an
army of the unemployed known as coxy's
army marched on dc demanding public
works projects to replace their lost
jobs while the newspapers covered them
with sympathy cleveland refused to budge
unshakable in his belief that it wasn't
the government's place to provide for
the destitute even worse was the pullman
strike of 1894 that year workers downing
tools at the pawn car yards near chicago
triggered a nationwide railroad strike
rather than negotiate cleveland sent in
the national guard over the protest of
illinois governor fighting broke out and
dozens of strikers were killed the
strike breaking effectively wiped out
support for the democrats in the
industrial north yet it would be his
response to something else that truly
shattered cleveland's party the clash
between silver and gold
[Music]
free silver is one of those issues
forgotten today but which seriously
whipped people up in the late 19th
century the basic idea is that a whole
bunch of dudes wanted a monetary policy
backed by both gold and silver which
they felt would increase everyone's
prosperity while a whole bunch of other
dudes wanted only to issue money
strictly backed by the nation's gold
reserves in this battle cleveland was
fighting gold but his party's southern
and western wing was riding the silver
chariot now this might have been fine
had president harrison not signed an act
mandating the government by colossal
sums of silver each month then issue
notes that could be exchanged for either
silver or gold coin something cleveland
was certain was damaging the economy
that's maybe all a bit complicated but
don't worry if you don't follow the
important part is that cleveland quickly
overturned president harrison's silver
purchase act it was a move the free
silver types in his party would never
forgive the 1894 midterms were to grover
cleveland's presidency what covid was to
2020 with the industrial north against
him and the silver supporting west
infuriated cleveland oversaw the worst
midterm results in u.s history remember
the 2010 republican wave well it was
barely a ripple compared to 1894.
democrats saw over 110 seats swept away
in the house the largest voter
realignment since the civil war mortally
wounded president cleveland tried to
stumble on but with his health on the
line doing so would soon become
impossible back in 1893 cleveland had
discovered a tumor inside his mouth and
had it removed in a secret operation
onboard a ship worried that the illness
would be taken as a sign of weakness the
result was a president forced to deal
with all of this crap in his second term
while also trying to hide the fact that
he was now partially sporting an
artificial jaw behind his trademark
mustache it must have been hell and with
all the bad news around him
it only got worse now we don't want to
give the impression cleveland's second
term was all failure he had a major
foreign policy win mediating a brewing
conflict between venezuela and britain
with mediating here basically meaning
threatening to knock those slimmies out
if they tried anything he also succeeded
in replenishing the country's depleted
gold reserves even if he had to rely on
guys like jp morgan to do so still the
overall feeling was of a man well maybe
not drowning but certainly flailing
splashing around desperately as hungry
shark circle just
waiting for their chance not that
cleveland would give republicans the
opportunity by the time 1896 rolled
around cleveland had fallen out so much
with his own party that it's doubtful he
could have gotten re-nominated even if
he wanted to instead the president
stepped aside to let some new blood take
over he probably hoped his remaining
supporters would force through a
candidate in his mold but no that summer
democrats nominated the free silverite
william jennings bryan who famously
declared in a speech you shall not press
down on the brow of labor this crown of
thorns you shall not crucify mankind on
a cross of gold it was a total
repudiation of everything cleveland had
stood for a straight dash from fiscal
conservatism into the arms of unabashed
populism the only cold comfort was that
bryan would get trashed in the election
that november william mckinley won the
republicans their biggest landslide
since 1872. grover cleveland left the
white house on march the 4th 1897
convinced his party had stabbed him in
the back and fallen prey to unhinged
extremists in some ways he was right
here he was the only democrat who'd won
since the civil war the only one who'd
sit in the white house into woodrow
wilson and his party was basically
telling him
don't let the door hit you on your way
out although he'd live another 11 years
settling into a pleasant retirement in
princeton new jersey he'd never forgive
this perceived betrayal cleveland died
on june 24 1908 his last words were
reported to have been i have tried so
hard to do right and really they sum up
the man rather well as the most
conservative democrat to occupy the
white house post-civil war cleveland
seems at least on fiscal policy more
like calvin coolidge than fdr certainly
he was inflexible on this issue
committed to a vision of america led by
a president who promoted talent kept a
sound eye on the nation's finances and
did little to interfere in people's
daily lives that's not necessarily a bad
thing maybe it even sounds ideal to you
it's just a shame this vision didn't
reflect the economic realities of the
1890s today grover cleveland is usually
ranked by historians somewhere in the
middle certainly no james buchanan star
disaster but also far from being great
that may be because our view of what the
presidency is has changed whereas
cleveland's voters were happy with a
guardrail against congress people
nowadays prefer hearing about guys like
teddy roosevelt activist presidents who
used the office to change the nation and
honestly who can blame them for guys
like us making history videos the active
presidents are always the best but it's
perhaps worth remembering that sometimes
there are other ways to lead a country
ways that are less showy but are still
effective he may only be remembered as a
trivia point today but grover cleveland
was also a unique leader one whose
non-consecutive tenures
deserve to be remembered
[Music]